[Music]
our minds urge to soar to the cosmos but
evolution by natural selection is driven
by
different goals
natural selection it cares about
survival and propagation of our genetic
material our eyes in particular they
evolve for the various earthbound
challenges faced by our forebears and
surely not to do things like examine the
rings of saturn the andromeda galaxy or
the black hole sagittarius a star
there's
just not much survival value in any of
those undertakings
and so as our minds have developed and
as our drive to explore the wider
landscape of reality has become ever
stronger we've realized that we need to
leverage technology to enhance and
augment and extend the bare senses that
evolution has provided
now an essential move in this direction
was not motivated by astronomy the
history is a bit murky but
sometime in the early 1600s in the
netherlands an eyeglass maker named hans
lippershay realized that by
looking through an appropriate
combination of glass lenses he could in
his own description
see things far away
as if they were nearby explaining well
the name the device would ultimately
bear the telescope from the ancient
greek tele meaning far and scopos
meaning to see
the description also explains why an
immediate interest in the telescope came
from
you guessed it the military
now as word of this delightful invention
spread rapidly others tried their hand
at fashioning telescopes and it was
around
1609
that galileo galilei built his own
version and was among the first to use
it as a tool for a series of
astronomical observations allowing him
and others to reveal remarkable
qualities of the heavens which to that
point
were completely hidden
the moons of jupiter
the phases of venus the rocky pockmarked
surface of the moon and the fact that
the sun marked by sunspots
is rotating in short order
various innovators among them the great
isaac newton realized that curved
mirrors could bend and focus the
trajectories of light rays much as
curved glass curved lenses do and yet
can be much easier to grind and use
because they're much lighter i mean
after all the entire thickness of a lens
is responsible for focusing light while
for a mirror only its thin surface
matters
and so in the decades and centuries it
followed scientists leveraged this and
many other innovations to build
telescopes that could gather ever more
light allowing us to peer ever farther
and with ever greater resolution into
the depths of space
and with each advance our knowledge of
the cosmos increased and refined from
the discovery of star forming nebulae
neutron stars
black holes
distant galaxies the expansion of space
and the microwave background radiation
the more powerful our tools for
observing the universe the more
surprises we've found now
both theorists like myself and
astronomers undertaking the observations
we
we live for those days when observations
reveal something
startling something that does not fit in
something that forces us to rethink our
theories and one of the most striking
examples of recent memory one that
frankly we are still trying to sort out
came from observations in the 1990s
showing that the expansion of space
is speeding up it's accelerating
suggesting the possibility of a still
deeply mysterious diffuse anti-gravity
presence of fusing space which we call
dark energy but notwithstanding that
we've named it
we still don't know exactly what it is
the hubble space telescope played a big
part in that monumental discovery and
many others too and floating a few
hundred miles above the distorting
effects of the earth's atmosphere the
hubble space telescope's observations
have indeed been a game changer
propelling our understanding of the
cosmos to a whole new level
now
the successor to the hubble space
telescope called the james webb space
telescope decades in the making is
poised for launch
on a longer journey this new space
telescope will float about a million
miles away from earth at a special
location tailor-made by the laws of
physics to keep the telescope
continually in line with the earth
and the sun now we'll talk about why
that is shortly but
when you consider
the massive size and extraordinary
precision of this telescope and you can
get a
feel for it from this full-scale model
that
we hosted at the world science festival
back in 2010
that
million-mile journey will be
nerve-racking to say the least but with
extraordinary testing and numerous
fail-safes the project scientists and
engineers are confident that all will go
smoothly
or at least
smoothly enough
it is
incredibly exciting and
not just to scientists
artists from around the country have
been inspired by the grandeur of this
instrument and by its potential to give
insight into questions ranging from
how did the universe begin
when did the first stars form are there
signs of life on other planets
i'd say it's possible
perhaps even likely that this new space
telescope will be looked back upon by
future generations as a turning point in
humanity's understanding
of the universe
tonight
we are honored to be joined by some of
the leaders behind the james webb space
telescope as well as those who will be
among its first users and they're here
to discuss the potential of this
remarkable new way of exploring the
cosmos
[Music]
our first guest is adam reese who is the
bloomberg distinguished professor at
johns hopkins university and a
distinguished astronomer at the space
telescope science institute in baltimore
maryland
re-study supernovae and his observations
of these exploding stars established the
paradigm shaking result
that the universe is expanding at an
accelerating rate for which he shared
the 2011 nobel prize he joins us from
his office in baltimore welcome adam
our next guest is john mather who is a
senior astrophysicist in the
observational cosmology laboratory at
nasa's goddard space flight center and
is the senior project scientist on the
james webb space telescope
in 2006 he shared the nobel prize for
work using nasa's kobe satellite to
measure the heat radiation from the big
bang
that result helps solidify the big bang
as the prevalent theory for the origin
of the universe he joins us from his
home outside of washington d.c
welcome john
next we have avena vondishook who is a
professor of molecular astrophysics at
loddon observatory in the netherlands
and is the 2018 complete prize laureate
in astrophysics she is netherlands lead
scientist for the james webb space
telescope the former president of the
international astronomical union and is
a renowned pioneer in the field of astro
chemistry she joins us from germany
where she is doing research at the max
planck institute welcome
avina
okay finally we have natalie battaglia
who holds the presidential chair at the
university of california santa cruz
where she is the director of
astrobiology prior to that she was a
research astronomer at nasa where she
was the lead scientist on the kepler
mission
a space telescope designed to find
planets orbiting other stars she joins
us from portland oregon
welcome natalie and welcome
to you all
all right guys it's uh exciting time
the james webb space telescope you know
25
years in the making is uh
soon to blast off on its mission to
roughly a million or so miles from the
earth to start its scientific work
so i thought it would be good to start
with a focus on the instrument itself
and then we'll turn to some of the
fundamental science that many of you
plan to do using the james webb space
telescope now
most people
are more familiar with the hubble space
telescope so
john if you could just get us going here
i know it's not exactly an
apples-to-apples comparison but how
powerful
is say the james webb compared to hubble
i mean we know about the beautiful
hubble images that have given us insight
into black holes in the centers of
galaxies giving us insight into the
expansion of the universe
how much more powerful
above that device is the james webb
well in round numbers we say it's 100
times more powerful but that's because
we can't really compare apples and
oranges so
the web telescope can do things that the
hubble can't do at all so the hubble
observes that ultraviolet wavelengths
visible wavelengths and just a little
bit of the infrared
and the web telescope starts with red
wavelengths and goes all the way out to
28 microns which is much longer and and
shows us new things
so
we've never been able to see that well
at those longer wavelengths we do have
or i did have telescopes in space that
could pick up these longer wavelengths
but they're done
the spitzer space telescope is too far
away now for us to talk to it
so this is it this is the great next
step for astronomy adam
from the standpoint of someone whose
work is in cosmology
why is the infrared a natural place and
a sweet spot from the theoretical
standpoint to do observations
right well so the james webb has this
you know really this super power of
being able to observe uh very far to the
red because it is so cold and there's
more or less i would say two basic
things we like to look at in the
universe one is
uh distant objects uh which are greatly
redshifted by the expansion of space and
so if you want to look very far back in
time you actually have to look red
and so the sensitivity of jwst in the
red is fantastic
and then unfortunately there is a lot of
dust or grit in the universe and it
obscures some of the objects that we use
as lamp posts to measure and gauge the
universe and so that red capability also
allows us to see through the dust and so
we will get a clearer view and a more
distant view by being able to observe
further to the red evina what's the
timeline between launch and starting to
actually take data
that's actually quite a long timeline um
because first uh after launch uh the the
telescope needs to start unfolding um
the sunshield needs to sun shield needs
to to to spread out and unfold that's
that's going to be a critical step i
think that happens all in the first week
it of course needs to cruise
to what we call the lagrangian point
where it's uh it's going to be for
the whole period of its observations
but then it needs to cool it takes time
to to simply cool down the telescope um
and so all together it's going to be a
month
before
the instruments start to be turned on
and and before we start getting the
first data uh in fact the whole
commissioning period takes about six
months
six months and is there a point in that
sequence of events where
everyone finally breathes a sigh of
relief is there sort of one major hurdle
that once you clear that
we're good to go or is it just every
step of the way something could go wrong
well i think that first you know two
weeks are clearly going to be crucial
with all the the unfolding of the sun
shield the telescope the secondary that
that comes out that's going to be
crucial but then also turning on all of
these instruments one by one and then
checking out that they're still working
i think that's everybody's going to be
um you know quite tense on the other
side
yeah so natalie um both john and avina
mentioned
that this
the web telescope is going to this
lagrange point the l2 point as we call
it if you take a course in orbital
mechanics why why that location
and and and how far is that from earth
the lagrange point is beyond the orbit
of the moon so it's far away and that's
great for astronomy because you don't
have
thermal and light effects coming from
the earth in the sun
with the kepler mission for example we
had
instrument stability
the instrument stability was affected by
the
detailed position of the spacecraft in
relation to the earth and the sun
so you want to be far away from those
effects in order to have very high
stability of your instruments and and i
gather that the lagrange point is chosen
because it'll keep an alignment between
the telescope earth and the sun so that
relative to each other they'll stay in a
nice stable configuration so the
conditions the heat from the sun heat
from the earth will be
conditions that will be stable over time
and this hopefully the heat shield will
shield all the delicate equipment and
it'll be able to take take its data
going forward now of course
hubble is still
going strong at some you know 30 odd
years later but
we're hearing that the web has a more
finite lifetime what's the difference
between the two
well okay on the hubble there's nothing
that's being used up as they go it
doesn't need fuel to keep pointing
itself or doing anything so it just
needs to keep on going around the earth
and finally it'll
gravity will pull it in because of the
drag of air so that's what sets the
ultimate life of the hubble for the web
we need a little bit of fuel to help
point to the telescope and to keep it in
the right orbit so when we run out of
that that's our ultimate limit aside
from that it's chances that we take with
all those electronic parts that will or
will not last of ever
so that's what sets the limit for the
web
uh we're actually carrying fuel for at
least 10 years of flight operations and
if we are lucky it might last 20 or more
it's interesting that you say that
because that was that's actually going
to be my follow-on question i was going
to say that if i was a project scientist
i would have said we cannot go beyond
five years and then when it went 10 15
or 20 it would have been a miracle but
now you're on the record that it might
go 10 or 20. which uh i i love the
optimism so so that's fantastic thank
you yeah well i am optimistic
but this is the first time for this kind
of equipment and so is the uncertainty
in the life literally the uncertainty in
the amount of fuel that it will require
to redirect and so forth or uh is it
sort of a best case scenario that if
everything goes according to plan and we
don't have to keep reorienting then the
fuel might last that much longer yeah
well the biggest uncertainty is how well
is the ariane 5 rocket do because we
need a little bit of fuel just to
correct in case it doesn't do the exact
orbit that it's supposed to do
so we have to reserve some for that if
we're lucky and it does a really good
job then we have much longer life for
the observatory itself with hubble when
it went up there was an issue at first
right the the mirror wasn't ground to i
guess the exact specifications necessary
and a kind of contact lens needed to be
uh inserted later on
when you're talking about a telescope
that's beyond the moon maybe like four
times the distance to the moon we're
presumably we're not going to be able to
have any missions to fix it if something
goes wrong or or can we or is that just
out of the question that's what makes me
most nervous the most nervous about this
mission is the fact that it's not
serviceable like hubble
so we talk about the launch and we're
all very nervous about
the launch period and turning on each of
these instruments and making sure
everything goes well during the
commissioning period but i will actually
be nervous throughout the lifetime of
this mission over the five or ten years
that it flies
because things age instruments can have
glitches we've seen that in the past
with other space telescopes
and we want the instruments to be
healthy for the duration for as long as
we have fuel on the spacecraft to
operate so it's it's an issue throughout
the lifetime of web because it's not
serviceable maybe one day it will be i
do hope that one day we can send either
robots or humans out to the lagrange
point in order to service our telescopes
because that is such a valuable place to
put our astronomical instruments but for
now that's not possible and that's
that's
going to keep us awake at night i have
anxiety dreams sometimes about what i'm
going to cook for dinner the next night
i mean
i i don't know that i'd be able to sleep
with that i mean how's your your state
of anxiety over the upcoming launch
we've seen all these vibration tests of
the the instruments and i was always
relieved when it came out still in one
piece after these vibration tests but
that's indeed going to be a very
exciting period the launch
so can you give us a sense of of of the
the scale of this telescope i mean i've
seen
the hexagonal mirrors up close and
personal but but give a sense how big
are they how many of them are there and
ultimately what will the unfolded size
of the instrument be okay well the big
mirror that we need to collect the
starlight is actually about 21 feet
across
it's made out of 18 big golden hexagons
and they're actually ultra light
so that you would be able to lift a
single golden hexagon because they're
not solid gold they're made of very
lightweight beryllium covered with gold
because that's the best reflector for
infrared and it is huge 21 feet across
is bigger than the rocket
so and it's got to be protected from the
heat of the sun by an umbrella we call
it a sunshade and it's five layers of
metallized plastic that are as big as a
tennis court
so all of that has to be folded up
origami style very carefully to go in
the top of the rocket and so my
understanding is in some of the early
tests at least one of the early tests
that sunshield actually ripped is that
is that is that what happened and how
did you respond to that and
are you confident that we're good to go
in in this round yeah
so we actually have unfolded it several
times and each time we look very
carefully is there an even a little tiny
scratch
so
we have found a few little tiny cuts
where we said that should not be so we
put little patches over those and we say
what made that happen can we fix that so
yes we've repaired everything that we
can imagine that would never make it cut
again so we think it's good to go so now
let's also now turn to
the work that you're going to be heading
up which has to do with
planets and and planetary atmospheres so
it can give us a sense of of what the
motivation is and how you're going to go
about this particular project with the
james webb when i mean as john said webb
started construction in something like
1995 in 1995 that was the year that the
very first planet orbiting another
sun-like star was discovered so when
webb was constructed we were only
beginning to learn about other worlds
orbiting other stars today we have over
4 000 over 4 500 known planets orbiting
other stars and we have some
many surprises that were revealed over
these last two decades two and a half
decades
and you know when i when i look back on
this discovery i kind of imagine
different epochs different stages in our
development the first 10 years was kind
of like postage stamp collecting you
know every one discovery of a new world
was really celebrated and and poured
over
but then in 2009 nasa's kepler mission
launched and we were no longer
discovering one planet at a time now we
were discovering hundreds even thousands
at a time and that enabled another epoch
of studying exoplanet demographics
exoplanets as populations and what we
learned from kepler is that the
diversity of planets in our galaxy far
exceeds the diversity of planets in our
own solar system
and and now
25 years later after that first
discovery we are literally knocking on
the door of a new epoch of exploration
which is the study of exoplanet
atmospheres and it's going to give us a
new lens on their diversity
when you think about earth's atmosphere
it's this thin little layer that is
hovering right above the earth's crust
if you try to imagine
measuring properties of an atmosphere at
the distances that we're talking about
it seems
mind-bogglingly difficult how do you go
about gaining insight into something
that's so thin at such an enormous
distance
yeah
you you asked john earlier what is the
power of web you know over hubble
besides the fact that we have 10 times
the collecting area so we get more
photons that allows us to increase the
precision of our measurements so we can
see very tiny features of these you know
from these very small exoplanets but
also
web is a spectroscopic machine we're
going to be looking in color space
hubble produced these very famous images
that we all know and love and web will
produce amazing images of the cosmos as
well
but what we're also going to be doing
with web is collecting light from
astrophysical objects like exoplanets
spreading that light out into a rainbow
and looking at that rainbow with very uh
close scrutiny and that will allow us to
see the chemical fingerprints that an
atmosphere leaves on the light
for exoplanets with web what we're going
to do well we're going to observe them
in many different ways but one of the
primary ways is to observe the star
when the planet is transiting across the
surface and when that happens this very
thin layer of the atmosphere will
intercept some of the photons from the
star on its way to our telescope and
then we will spread that light out to
into into a rainbow and disentangle
these chemical fingerprints from the
atmosphere from the chemical
fingerprints of the host star for
example so do you have any sense right
now of what fraction of exoplanets have
a significant atmosphere that's a great
question and i would have to say for the
earth-like planets we don't yet know
you know we've done this game a little
bit with hubble we have observed about
a couple dozen
of what we call hot jupiters maybe down
to a hot neptune sized planet we've
looked at them atmospherically at their
atmospheric signatures with hubble and
with a very rare narrow slice of this
color space
that captures water features for example
from the water molecule
giant planets like jupiter have very
thick hydrogen rich envelopes in terms
of an atmosphere a large percentage of
the mass of jupiter for example is due
to this envelope or what planetary
scientists would call an atmosphere when
you go down to the terrestrial size
planets especially when they're orbiting
very close to their host star
we think that those atmospheres get
stripped away relatively easily and so
we want to know what fraction have
atmospheres because that's going to have
significant implications for whether or
not they are potential abodes of life
and so that is exactly one of the things
that we want to learn is what fraction
of terrestrial size planets actually
have atmospheres when you look at an
atmosphere of say a terrestrial size
planet presumably
finding something that has a composition
not unlike earth that presumably that's
that's the home run
but are there other
markers within an atmosphere that you
will be looking for
and if you see them you can say there
is some
case to be made that a living system may
be responsible for those markers well
webb was not designed to be a life
finder
and we have a lot to learn before we
start looking in earnest for
biosignatures these signatures of life
imparted by life that has actually taken
a global toehold of a planet and
influence the atmosphere in a global way
that's remotely detectable you know i
mentioned that kepler uncovered this
diversity of planets one of the things
right out the gate that kepler
discovered is that the most common type
of planet in the galaxy orbiting in the
inner solar systems is a type of planet
we don't even have in our solar system
you know in our solar system we've got
the tiny rocky things orbiting nearby
we've got the big giants orbiting far
away
um
but in the galaxy it turns out that the
most common type of planet is something
in between
and we don't know what its nature is
it's been suggested that a large
fraction of these planets started out as
something like neptune but in the
dynamical formation and evolution
processes of
of planetary systems those planets could
have migrated inwards towards their host
star so what happens if you take a
neptune and you plunk it down in an
orbit like earth's what's going to
happen to it well scientists say that
what happens to it is the hydrogen
envelope gets completely stripped away
leaving
a rocky core
so rocky cores are great for life right
is that a potential abode of life does
that broaden the number of landscapes
available for for life in the galaxy we
don't know so we want to understand that
mysterious population that we don't have
in our own solar system and in doing so
by looking at the atmospheres we will
have diagnostics that allow us to
understand
all of the physical processes that
sculpt a planetary atmosphere and leave
something after a billion or two billion
years where life could or could not
take a toll hold so that most common of
all planets revealed by those surveys
can you give us a sense of what those
planets will i mean how big are they if
they're bigger than us but not as big as
say jupiter where do they fit in the
range are terrestrial planets let's do
it in terms of earth units let's call
earth one
so earth venus are about one earth
radius mars is about half that mercury
is about the size of our moon a little
bit bigger the next largest thing in our
solar system is neptune and uranus at
four times the size of the earth
jupiter ten times the size of the earth
so in this range between one and four
you know we don't really have anything
in our solar system unless you want to
keep looking out at the kuiper belt in
the very distant
regions of the solar system maybe
there's something still lurking there
that's yet to be discovered
but as far as we know today there's
nothing in this range of one to four and
the most common type of planet
that uh we know of is in the size range
of like one and a half to two and a half
earth radius earth radii am i right that
is your daughter
um
a lead scientist on a mission to
explore those kinds of planets is that
correct
yes she is she's the principal
investigator of one of the largest
programs that was selected for cycle one
that will observe about a dozen planets
in that size range in order to better
understand their diversity and how they
transform themselves from
something more like neptune that has a
hydrogen envelope which we call a
primordial atmosphere by the way because
it's it's formed we think during the
planet formation process versus the
atmosphere of earth in comparison with
the atmosphere of earth which we believe
was mostly outgassed we call it a
secondary atmosphere because it was
outgassed later in the earth in earth's
evolution
and so yes my daughter is a
research astronomer at nasa ames
research center and she is the pi of
that mission and i'm actually a
co-investigator on it as well well
that's great so adam let's turn to um
one of the
main science
projects that the web will be focused
upon which is in the arena of early
universe cosmology and it's interesting
because what i'd like to discuss for a
few minutes is something that
was not on
the scientific radar when the web was
being built it's this issue called the
hubble tension
having to do with
measurements in the last few years that
have really begun to show potential
discrepancy in our observations of
cosmological qualities of the world and
our theoretical understanding of
cosmology has to do with expansion of
space i'll let you explain it to us but
i'll simply note that over the years the
rate of expansion of space has been this
vital quantity that we have been trying
to nail down so can you give us a sense
of where we stand on understanding the
expansion rate of the universe the
tension that we're now under and what
webb might do to help resolve it sure so
in the last 20 years we've developed a
new model of cosmology and we think we
understand the universe and can
therefore make predictions and one of
the key predictions is to observe the
universe shortly after the big bang with
the cosmic micro microwave background
and essentially calibrate the state of
the universe then how fast it was
expanding what it was composed of and
then use our understanding of the
physics of the universe to really
predict or extrapolate to the present
time how fast should the universe be
expanding now
and then we measure the expansion rate a
number called the hubble constant and
the
hubble space telescope was designed
largely to measure the hubble constant
to about 10 precision and that was
successful and uh maybe we should have
quit while we were ahead because we
continued to measure better with the
newer instruments in hubble and as we
approached percent level precision which
is about where we are now we've begun to
see i guess sort of cracks uh in this
sort of uh uh standard model our ability
to go from end to end of the universe
and explain the dynamics of the
expanding universe is falling short
there's a discrepancy now and it's
becoming quite
significant and so hubble has left us
with this kind of cliffhanger
if you will and we hope that the james
webb space telescope can step in and
sort of help us resolve or better
understand uh
what's going on so in terms of the
actual numbers for those in the audience
who like the details
what is the best observational number
that we have for the expansion rate and
and what would we have anticipated based
on the theory
right right so before hubble launched it
was somewhere between 50 and 100 the
universe somewhere between 10 and 20
billion years old and then after
these observations and careful
measurements uh we're now down to a
range of 67 to 73 which sounds like a
lot of progress you know the glasses
have full here we understand a great
deal about the universe the problem is
the cosmic microwave background data
says it should be 67 plus or minus 0.5
and the local measurements uh generally
coalesce around 73 plus or minus one and
a half or so and so this has become
uncomfortably far apart and suggests
maybe there's another wrinkle in the
standard model of the universe maybe
uh these concepts or these realities
like dark energy and dark matter are a
little more complicated a little less
vanilla
have some other important physics that
we're not including
in our description of the universe so
just quickly when you say say 67 or 73
can just give a sense of what those
numbers are telling us about the
expansion of space so they're in funny
units that we call kilometers per second
per megaparsec so they say every time
you go out another megaparsec which is
like three million light years the
universe is expanding 67 to 73
kilometers per second faster but you
could think of that number as a doubling
rate so uh at that expansion rate it
means you know the universal double
about every 10 billion years at this
point got it so john you know certainly
over the course of my
career in physics
i you know i don't work on on
observations and and uh the cosmological
parameters are more of an input to me as
opposed to something that i've spent any
time ever trying to determine but i've
i've witnessed a tension between
different groups claiming different
values for the expansion of space over a
long period of time do you consider this
tension to be different from what we
have heard in the past or do you
anticipate somehow it'll all just work
out and the standard cosmological theory
will still work at the end of the web
observations good question so uh when i
started in on this world of cosmology
there really wasn't much of a number
when uh adam says 50 or 100 let's like
we don't know
and so at that time the the disputes
between those groups were extremely
vigorous and people were quite sure they
were right and now we know neither group
was quite right so i'm an experimenter i
like to measure things and i'm always
afraid that it's my fault when i get an
answer that somebody doesn't agree with
so
that's my guess of course that we're
making some
error in our measurement and nature has
just fooled us about something but that
makes us a little bit blind to the
possibility that maybe nature has really
got something to tell us that there's
something that not in our story that we
might just be happening on and we have
to be really really careful
so my expectation this time is is why
wouldn't why wouldn't it be complicated
nature is always complicated so i would
not be
surprised a bit if we are happening on
something really remarkable
and if i could just jump in here for one
second um i will say what's really
interesting about the current moment is
in the past when as john said people
disagreed about the value of this number
they thought they were measuring the
same thing they were measuring it
locally they were using the same tools
so we knew both things couldn't be right
what's so fascinating about this is
we're actually measuring this quantity
starting at opposite ends of the
universe and so in this case it's
possible that both measurements are
right and it's telling us something
about the story we use to connect the
two and so while i can't tell you yet
what the answer is you know that makes
it i think a much more interesting
moment because uh it has the potential
to give us a clue about the universe as
opposed to just uh well who's right
right now
it would be asking too much for you to
to as you say tell us what the ultimate
answer will be but there are some
potential stories on the table
uh do any of them strike you as
plausible at the moment or are they all
just sort of cooked up to try to make
things worse right you know i'm in a
funny position to to tell you what's
plausible because you know 20 years ago
when we saw the universe was
accelerating you know it was attributed
to dark energy and a cosmodrome constant
and as you know there's about 120 orders
of magnitude gap between a sort of
quantum level understanding of the cost
module constant and what we actually see
so
is that plausible you know
are we comfortable with that explanation
so
in that context some of the things that
are suggested now
are you know another episode of dark
energy before the universe became
transparent um dark matter decaying over
time
another relativistic particle like a
neutrino believe it or not any of these
things can explain why the universe is
not tracking the simplest cosmological
model and so as an observer i struggle
with what's natural
uh what's surprising you know the
universe is so surprising to me that you
know i i find i don't have a good prior
for just evaluating what seems
reasonable and it could also be that
einstein's general theory of relativity
which has done a pretty good job at
describing a lot maybe there's some
modification being hinted at and yet on
the largest scales of the universe when
we apply general relativity we get these
interesting phenomena that we struggle
with dark matter dark energy this extra
uh expansion that is looks like the
hubble tension so you know maybe on
large scales we've finally broken
general relativity it's it's you know
it's hard to say so when do you start
your observing run i mean do you have
time that's already reserved on the
telescope yeah a specific window yeah so
the so the first year of the telescope
hopefully it's working well we will uh
and you know after it's calibrated we
will dive into
uh going back through hubble the
telescope's footsteps and greatly
improving both using the superpower of
greater red sensitivity but also greater
resolution so we look at stars in other
galaxies to calibrate the expansion of
the universe and like if you were
looking at a cloud of fireflies you
would want to be able to pick out the
individual fireflies to determine you
know how bright they are and how far
away they are well hubble kind of tends
to blur those fireflies together and so
with jwst we will get such a crisp
vision that we will separate the
fireflies and do a better job of picking
out the individual ones and we will be
able to improve the precision of
measurements and is there a date certain
though is it like june 12th at 11 23
your run begins is it scheduled at that
level scheduling the telescope is very
complicated as you heard we want to uh
reserve and conserve fuel and so a very
tightly choreographed schedule is built
that keeps the telescope from having to
move around too much and so
after it's settled after they know how
much fuel they have after they know the
configuration then they build that
schedule and you know it'll mostly be
just the the ability to
most conserve the movements of the
telescope and so when your run is
happening is it is it like a 24 hour a
day data collection enterprise it is
unlike hubble also which used to get
blocked or occulted by the earth every
45 minutes jwst will be able to observe
pretty much all the time and you know
we'll probably get some notice just a
couple weeks before that our time is
coming up and we'll have a block of time
and then you know the data will be taken
and beamed down and you know we'll be
very excited to look at the first day is
it almost real time i mean can you sit
at your your your
computer and and sort of see the data
coming right
if it's like hubble you know it'll tend
to be probably an hour or two delay not
too much and how long does it take to
think after getting the data to do the
analysis and announce something to the
world
you know it it depends a great deal on
um
the nature of the data and uh you know
until we see it you know what
complexities are there what you know how
what configuration jwst ends up in when
hubble launched as you said there were
problems and so you had this this kind
of strange aberration in the images and
you had to use sophisticated software to
try to remove it so in situations like
that it can take years in other cases
you could look at the first picture and
go oh look there's nothing around the
objects we were looking at they were
clean as a whistle and uh we can tell
you what this means so you know it's
going to depend and and what's the size
of your team that will be doing that
data analysis is it you in a small group
or is this a massive yeah yeah yeah
that's one of the one of the elegant
features i think of all of these space
telescopes is you know they're massive
endeavors that involve you know tens of
thousands of people and yet the research
teams for individual investigations can
be quite small they can be you know half
a dozen people uh that's uh in our case
you know somewhere between half a dozen
and a dozen people and so you know you
have these sort of micro investigation
teams spread throughout the ability to
use these facilities very different than
like a uh a particle accelerator yeah
aveeno let's turn
toward
physics astronomy that's a little bit um
closer to us both in space and time so
your work is focused on trying to
understand the formation of stars and
planets
and
the web is meant to give you an image of
the universe that that is actually
so new no one's ever seen it before so
just give us a sense of of what you
imagine that to be and how the physics
will allow you to see where no one has
seen before yeah no it's uh it's all
about sort of origins uh that
encompasses the science that we will be
doing so origins of stars but especially
also origins of planets
how are planets formed in these rotating
disks of gas and dust and and ultimately
that of course comes back also to the
question how how we were formed we
meaning our solar system
and of course for that
we cannot turn the clock back to see
exactly what our young solar system
looked like but we can definitely go to
you know many nearby
regions in which new stars are being
born and new planets are being born and
then look at these young systems and get
a picture of what it will be now you
talked actually about images but
to me it's not going to be about the
images it's really going to be about the
spectra
about getting the fingerprints
of the material there
for me actually one spectrum is worth a
thousand images and that's yeah so tell
us why why why why is the spectre so
vital to the work you want to do
that's because uh there in that you can
really see what a material is out of
which new solar systems are being uh
formed and then you have to think about
uh water but also about organic
molecules like methane like carbon
dioxide
like
acetylene
hydrogen cyanide
so there's all these molecules that have
their fingerprints exactly in this mid
infrared
wavelength range and
and it's not just one line we will see
hundreds of lines there maybe thousands
of lines
of these molecules and we can can really
then study them and model them tell how
many there are of each of these
molecules uh even more simple counts the
elements that are there oxygen carbon
nitrogen
the elements out of which we are made
ultimately
um
but we can also learn something about
say about temperature um because we have
so many lines the relative strengths of
these lines tells us something about
temperatures so so there's so much
information that we can get out of these
uh hundreds of lines so you know many of
us teach courses for students on on
various areas of astronomy physics i
certainly have taught students
about star formation about planet
formation
how well do we actually understand the
details of those processes and and what
what are the unknowns and and what do
you what do you hope to resolve with the
data yeah i mean that's it's a
a topic that is still unfolding very
much at this this moment because we now
have the ability to look deep into these
dusty clouds um
next to the james webb space telescope
that will be coming up also the atacama
large millimeter array on the ground is
is getting fantastic images now of
planets flowing discs uh things that
used to be just a blob
that we can now actually resolve
and we can see sort of the individual
you know rings and and and cavities in
these discs where planets are actually
forming at this very moment so the the
whole theory actually of planet
formation is is undergoing a a
revolution actually at this stage it's
certainly not a smooth project it goes
with all kinds of of humps and bumps in
order to bring sort of these tiny little
dust particles together into to grow
something that is bigger and bigger and
bigger and ultimately something like
like earth so we're at a very
interesting junction now and
jwst will certainly provide its uh uh
part of this this story it will be
particularly well suited to look at the
inner parts of the of the disk say in
our own solar system out to where saturn
is
um
so the inner region that's where we
actually think that the bulk of the
planets are being formed especially the
earth-like planets
um
whereas
the alma telescope is is very well
suited to look at the outer colder
regions so there's it could be a very
interesting synergy here and then and
bringing these two stories together
and so where where are you going to
initially
look i mean where are you going to point
the telescope is there a specific space
that you've already chosen where you're
going to focus yes yeah yeah yeah yeah
we're going to go basically to the
nearest regions in which new stars are
being born they are say
some 300 light years
away so we're looking really close to
home as close as possible to get the
maximum sensitivity to get the maximum
spatial resolution um so that's why we
like to to look close by and from from
precursor missions like the speech to
space telescope that john mentioned
earlier um sort of those pathfinders we
have already an indication as sort of
where to look
and so our first
targets are just going to be those where
we we know we will get lots of signal uh
but now we will be able to unravel that
signal that used to be sort of a a
single blurry feature will now start to
resolve itself into to hopefully 50 or
100 lines um so so yes we have a whole
program lined up for that and and so
just to give us a sense of of the
physics so you're
looking
within
environments that are are very dusty
dirty in some sense from the standpoint
of the data
that you want to
receive in some clean manner why is it
that the infrared
will
give you a clearer vision than anything
that we've used before say in the
visible or other parts of the spectrum
yeah it's it's really basically the the
extinction i mean think about it when
there's a lot of smoke in the atmosphere
you also know that you cannot look very
far then it's basically these dust
particles that absorb and scatter the
radiation and that means that you cannot
look very deep into a cloud at optical
wavelengths the light that we see with
our own eyes
but if you go to the infrared part then
a lot of that disappears and you can
really start to penetrate into these uh
these dusty clouds and so that is what
makes it so powerful that's uh and so
when does your when does your observing
begin is it also early on in the mission
or are you standing by he hopes we hope
so we hope so um i mean miri is actually
the the last instrument to be
commissioned so the last two weeks of
commissioning so we have to wait long
for that to as the instrument team sort
of to see the the first data
and that the actual observations uh of
the the the guaranteed time as we have
as instrument builders but also the
early release science projects
they will actually be taken as as soon
as possible after the launch and this
data being made immediately public so
so hopefully maybe by by june we'll get
a first taste of
what the data look like
so you mentioned the early release
programs so can you just give a sense of
what those are and why it's been
integrated into the mission yeah yeah i
mean i'm sure that natalie can tell even
more about those but
they were really
um planned in order to make sure that
the entire community had data as soon as
possible before the next call of the
proposal so
um we have had one call of proposals to
the general public
everybody basically being able to
propose for that um and uh
the next one has to be of course once
the uh observatory is successfully
launched but you can you know you need
to know sort of what the real quality is
of the data and in order to
secure that
that's basically why these early release
programs were planned uh to be executed
as as quickly as possible in the first
few months uh data immediately released
to the to the whole scientific community
and and then they can use that for the
next proposal call
and so you mention the general public
john
is it the case that anybody can apply
for time on on the space telescope yes
absolutely we call for proposals about
once a year
and we received over 1100 proposals from
many thousands of astronomers around the
world and everyone's eligible to propose
you still have to compete you have to
write a good proposal
but we got good proposals and we're very
happy with them uh so anyone's able able
to offer a proposal is there anyone that
you have accepted who's not
university-based oh i'm not sure about
that um but i i can tell you that about
10 of the proposals were led by graduate
students
uh so
people are very young and have great
ideas and we're pleased to give them the
data if i could jump in for one second
just afraid that nasa will now be
flooded with uh proposals is um it's
important in proposals for people to
usually recognize in the writers what is
known what has been done before and what
needs to be done and so
i don't want to discourage anybody out
there from having a great idea but it's
always important to check whether your
idea has been checked already before
writing a proposal absolutely essential
i i think you guys would hate me if all
of a sudden a million proposals come in
from all over the world
so vina natalie both of you
from 30 000 feet or maybe that's the
wrong unit of measure for this
conversation from a large distance are
in this area
of planet formation planet atmospheric
planet structure do your groups talk to
each other or is it that these projects
are fairly siloed and everybody just
uses the instrument for their particular
purpose or is there a cross conversation
that happens no no i mean i think
there's there's definitely a connection
between our topics and i think thanks to
jdbst there will be more and more
uh actually conversations between us
because um one of the the the broader
science goals is also
whether in the mature planets that uh
natalie is uh studying um whether say
the composition of that atmosphere the
amount of carbon and oxygen whether that
tells you something about where that
planet was formed where did it get its
carbon and oxygen how much did it get
and that's my part of the story because
i'm looking at it in the very early
stages and we're trying to link that how
much of that material from the outer
part of these these uh
solar nebula these these these discs at
which the planets form how much of that
material goes from the outer disk into
the inner disk and then makes it into a
planetary atmosphere so it will be
really fascinating i think in the uh
you know after a few years of jwst to
start to come
to to link our data together and and see
whether we can say something about how
and where uh those planets were actually
formed
yeah there are some really key
outstanding questions i mean if you go
back to 1995 the very first exoplanet
that was discovered right out the box
was a huge surprise something as large
as jupiter orbiting 10 times closer to
its parent star than mercury is to our
own sun how did it get there it defied
everything that we knew about planet
formation so the current thinking is
that planets that the formation process
is dynamic that the planets are
gravitationally interacting with one
another and with the disk from which
they formed they can spiral inwards or
drift outwards depending on the nature
of those gravitational interactions
so we want to test that hypothesis
and
avena is the alchemist she's getting all
of the molecules together and telling us
where those molecules are condensing out
so that when we observe the atmospheres
of these surprising hot jupiters we can
look at the ratios of different species
of molecules or elements and she'll tell
us where that planet was formed and then
from that we'll be able to confirm this
hypothesis that indeed they formed
farther out and then lost angular
momentum and spiraled in so do we have a
sense where our sun and initially formed
is that something which we can say with
any confidence well i mean certainly the
question as to where did our jupiter
originally formed i think that's a very
current question at the moment did it
form where it is located at this very
moment or did it form much further out
into the disk and then came inwards um
and jupiter is very much enhanced in its
oxygen uh in its nitrogen and where did
it get that because as natalie said
it's not just the gases it's it's really
also the condensing out into isis that
plays a huge role in this entire story
and and that is actually where jwst
excels because jb st can see not just
the gases it can also see the isis and
we can we can start actually in in some
disks where we have a fortunate uh
orientation and what is called an adjoin
orientation we can really look at
different lines of site actually through
that disk we can see not just the gas
but also the ices actually um that are
part of the building blocks of these new
planets so um so yes
we're going to have a very exciting
period there so based on what we know
now i'm sorry natalie go ahead this is
so important you know to be able to see
the ices in a disk
when we go out and we search for life
we're going in search of water
and we don't even have a clear
understanding about where our planet
earth got its oceans
there was an idea that the oceans were
delivered
to us by the collisions of comets that
came from the outer solar system but now
that thinking is kind of changing maybe
when earth formed there was already a
lot of ice in the disk that got
sequestered away into the rocks and then
later was outgassed and precipitated
down to form the oceans this is still an
outstanding question
so when we look at the discs from which
the planets form and we can actually see
ice in that disk it will help us to
better understand
where the water is and where the
potential abodes of life will be
so when you look at planet earth now and
our solar system now
is the general sense that we are
an anomaly relative to other things that
are more common out there or do you
think that ultimately we're just going
to be run of the mill
it's too early to say
i i've heard some scientists look at the
kepler data and conclude that earth is
anomaly an anomaly
because of the diversity
uh we see for example
uh
planetary systems in terms of
architecture of systems we see what we
call compact multis where you have a lot
of planets orbiting very close to the
star very tightly packed one close one
next to the other we know that our own
solar system all the planets orbit along
a plane that is kind of a pancake shape
these compact multis are so tightly
packed and neatly arranged they're not a
pancake they're more like a thin crepe
so you know you it's tempting to
conclude from that that the earth and
the solar system are unique but the
reality is that the kepler mission which
has the most information about planetary
demographics was not sensitive to an
exact
solar system analog for that we are
going to need future missions that help
to extend the demographic survey
all the way out to orbits of jupiter and
and to the smaller planets uh that are
more like earth-sun analogs
either of you willing to give a gut feel
for whether there's life out there when
i look at earth which is the only
example we have of a living world i
noticed that life got a toehold here at
least microbial life immediately as soon
as earth cooled enough so that oceans
could pool on the surface so that water
could pool on the surface of earth
microbial life appeared all the building
blocks were there you know we see amino
acids in the interstellar medium those
are the building blocks of proteins
nucleic acids etc
so all the building blocks are there
microbial life started immediately so uh
from that alone my gut feeling is that
it's easy to create microbial life and
that when the conditions are right it's
going to happen and we know that there
are billions of earth-like planets out
in the galaxy kepler taught us that so
so i think from that perspective yes and
then if you asked me what about more
complex life self-awareness for example
multi-cellular life or even intelligence
if you can define such a thing
that i don't know because i look at this
example of earth and i say well it took
two billion years
for eukaryotes to form these are the
true the branch of the tree of life that
humans are on
so that required perhaps oxygen in the
atmosphere as a result of
billions of years of photosynthesis from
algae on the on the surface
maybe that means that more complex life
is harder takes longer
but that said there are stars in our
galaxy that have been around for the
entire age of the galaxy you know 11 12
billion years
so i love to imagine what might happen
on such a planet how life might evolve
given 12 billion years yeah and had the
dinosaurs not been wiped out have they
not been wiped out who knows right we
may uh either we might not be here
talking or it might be a group of five
dinosaurs talking to one another
depending on how things uh evolve
exactly
so so john
with such a
a tight
schedule because of the tight lifetime
of the james webb space telescope
is there a provision for responding to
some unexpected exciting development
where you kind of
change the schedule reorient the
telescope because we just have got to
focus it upon something that we didn't
expect to happen absolutely there is if
you've got a reason to call us up and
say i've got something exciting we know
how to do that
you call up the director of the space
telescope science institute and you say
what your idea is and we'll get together
and talk about it
so we think it takes us about two days
to go through that human process of
deciding and then sending up the
commands to the observatory so yes
indeed if a
interstellar comet comes through and we
think it's real yes we can go look at it
or if we think uh something new is going
to crash into jupiter yes we can go look
at it yes
great so we've all we've been talking a
lot about the power of the james
webb telescope adam when you think about
your own research program let's say
things go maximally well with the web
telescope
what next i mean is there a new
instrument beyond that that would be
particularly well suited to the kinds of
things that you focus your attention on
right i think one of the lessons of the
hubble space telescope is that you have
these ideas of you know this is the
investigation we're going to do just
like this
and then at least half of the most
significant discoveries that came from
hubble we're not even on the drawing
board we're not in anybody's proposal
the first year we're not part of the way
the telescope was designed to do
something and so
you know it's very difficult you know as
they say to make predictions
particularly about the future
um
you know it depends what we learn and
inevitably you know it will require some
clever utilization of the instruments or
the you know the different capabilities
we have and so for that reason i think
nasa has always done a very good job and
and esa to make sure we sort of cover
the whole spectrum from you know
different wavelengths to different
resolutions you know maybe x-rays maybe
gamma rays maybe infrared
because you know it's hard to know which
of our senses is going to be the most
critical one to tell us the next thing
and so
yes depending on what we find it might
be gravitational waves in my instance um
that you know allow us a completely
independent way to look at the expansion
of the universe to tease out you know
whatever it is that's going on yeah and
so john even uh having both been
involved in in webb since the uh
earliest thinking about the project you
know what it takes
to to gather a consortium of of
scientists and engineers to get the
funding and so forth
so with that kind of lead time i hear
it's 25 years from like start to launch
are you thinking about that next device
now is it already
under development or in the planning
phase
well actually we do have the next one
under development it's called the nancy
grace roman space telescope
and it's
thought we might launch it in 2026 or so
so that's not so far off it's well along
and it was conceived
quite a long time ago
and it has a special concentration on
looking for his signs of the dark matter
in the dark energy so it's special for
that
and it will cover a lot of sky
because it has the ability to take 100
times as much sky at one bite as the
hubble can do so something rare and
unusual may turn up so that's an example
of what adam's mentioning that we don't
honestly know
what the future will hold because nature
has given us something that will be
surprising
after that we have lots and lots of
ideas
four great observatories were proposed
to
be evaluated by the national academy of
sciences
review panel called the decadal survey
so in a very short time we expect to
know what they said
and then we have some idea about which
of these things we may do next but from
my perspective we probably need them all
and it'll take us a long time to build
them
but yes
great things are coming
if i can interject sometimes what really
helps us is having some of these
capabilities working at the same time
because some of them like this the nancy
grace
roman telescope is a wide angle
telescope so it's kind of a finder scope
if you will whereas when we find
interesting things in the infrared that
it can
find we'll follow it up with the james
webb space telescope provided that it's
working at the same time and so you know
one of the beauties is you know really
we're heading into this golden age i
think of astronomy where we will have
you know hubble and the roman telescope
and jwst and large ground-based
telescopes all working sort of in
synergy because they each have a
different kind of superpower that allows
us to sort of do whatever it is this
science investigation needs
and so looking back over the past
25 years
john even all of you really
are there lessons learned regarding
mistakes that were made in the
development of the james webb space
telescope that will inform future
missions in a manner that you know say
will keep
the development time shorter that maybe
even keep budgets tighter anything of
that sort that emerged oh my goodness
well i think we certainly saw that early
ambitions for the price and this time
scale of the web telescope were just
wrong uh we were very ambitious and uh
and hopeful and um and with we might
have made some better plans if we
weren't quite so ambitious and hopeful
right away
uh so we certainly know that we don't or
at least at that time we did not
really know how to plan well enough
so current uh
ideas are much more carefully examined
to say well i don't believe that number
how about
being more cautious
so that's a big lesson
the other lesson is be ambitious anyway
because it's going to take a long time
whatever it is and it better be worth
all that effort so don't just make a
thing that's a little bit different make
something that's really spectacular and
then you'll be proud of it because
nobody else can ever do it the same as
you can
so that's what these new great
observatories are scheduled to do if
when we finally build them they will be
far beyond what we've got today so vina
natalie how about both of you for your
research programs the next phase and
natalie already made reference to the
need for another instrument to go beyond
even what james will be able to do what
do you envision
well
you made the reference or when you were
talking about an earth and its very thin
atmosphere and i i mentioned how just a
tiny fraction of photons will filter
through that atmosphere and take with it
the chemical fingerprint
it is very tiny i mean the scale height
of an of a terrestrial atmosphere is
like five kilometers
so
a tiny planet transiting in front of a
star is taking out one ten thousandth of
the light of the star and then the
atmosphere that thin atmosphere is one
two hundredth of that so it's a very
tiny signal that we have to tease out of
the data what i really want in order to
be able to see biosignatures is i want
all of the light that's reflecting off
of the surface of the planet and in
order to see that you need direct
imaging so we want a telescope that is
capable of very accurately
blocking out the starlight as if you
were holding up your thumb in the sky
and you could block out the starlight so
that you could see the very faint
planets reflecting and emitting light
in orbit around that star
and you have to do that very carefully
because those
planets are about 10 billion times
fainter than the star that they orbit
but once we can do that we will have
more photons that we can collect we will
play the same game we will spread them
out into a rainbow and we will
scrutinize those those features those
chemical fingerprints in the light but
with a bigger telescope that has higher
sensitivity and very good star
suppression technology we will have the
capability of detecting biosignatures
like oxygen from photosynthesis
for dozens of planets and this is one of
the ideas that has been studied in great
detail and is on
on up for consideration by the decadal
survey that we'll hear from at the at
the end of this month
and if we had strong evidence if these
biomarkers were to to really hit us in
the face in either the james webb or
future missions
can you ima what will the impact be on
on on life on planet earth
oh man just another copernican
revolution i mean
humans have been asking the question are
we alone since the dawn of time since
humans first existed since the first
human looked up at the sky and wondered
what was out there or saw a parallel
between those faint points of light and
our own sun
so i i think that looking up into the
sky and not feeling that existential
cosmic loneliness but knowing that every
point of light you see is not just a
star but a planetary system above you
know abounding with life that is going
to fundamentally change how we see our
place in the universe
vino how about you in the next next
mission that you would imagine beyond
this what what what in the best of all
worlds what would that be
yeah well first of all i think uh if any
new mission needs to go for this this
big jump forward so i fully agree with
john and and and adam that you need to
be ambitious and and make a uh create a
discovery space so to say because uh
you know a significant fraction of the
results are going to be dosed that we
didn't expect and that's actually the
thrill of the the discoveries uh that
we're gonna get and and that is because
we're opening up so much new parameter
space um where we may find things that
we we hadn't even imagined so so that's
the first lesson i think for for any new
uh telescope and the other
is is like like natalie said jwst is not
a life-finding
mission
we really need
another mission for that we are actually
now the first generation of
humans that actually has the technology
in order to do that because
we indeed need to be able to separate
the light from that
tiny little planet from the the mother
star so this direct imaging
and direct imaging and spectroscopy of
of those earth-like planets and then
looking for the designs of life so that
is an enormous technology development
that is ongoing at this moment but it's
now reaching sort of the maturity stage
that you can start to think about a uh
next mission you know it will be still
decades before that would be launched
but
again it's the the excitement that we
are now having
the capability in principle to to start
design that and and do that and that
that will be uh really transformative of
course in the in the results uh that we
would get done
somebody has one final question to all
of you oh no go ahead can i add one yeah
please absolutely go ahead just to add
one more thing you you asked how does
this impact humans every time we look
outwards
and push frontiers we always end up
turning inwards as well
as we look for life beyond the solar
system we have to consider the
conditions under which life could arise
in order to pinpoint the most likely
abodes of life so we consider the
extremes and when we do that we learn
something about the sustainability of
life right here on planet earth
searching for other planets makes me
love this one all the more it makes me
appreciate it and want to protect life
it makes me realize how valuable the
rise of this complexity in the universe
is
and makes me want to protect it so i
think that that's a very very important
impact on humanity the search for life
helps us to understand how we humans
can survive to the to the deep future
yeah it's a deeply important message and
one that actually does take us to the
final question that i wanted to ask
which
i'm happy if
each of you would be willing to chime in
it's a question i get asked a lot i i
know probably that you must get asked a
lot too and it has to do with money
right when we look at the the price tag
on the telescope you know i don't know
what it is but people kick around the
number 10 billion dollars one response
is look on the scales of of government
funding over the length of time over
which the money is spent that's actually
not that much money but 10 billion
certainly sounds like a lot of money so
adam what is your response when people
say hey is it should we be spending that
amount of taxpayer money on this kind of
an endeavor
right um
you know it's difficult to pick and
choose any individual investigation
telescope and say you know this one or
this one but you know what i speak to
more is this process of learning about
the natural world you know following our
curiosity and questioning the basic laws
of the universe i mean as you know when
einstein was trying to understand
gravity you know he didn't imagine he
was going to come up with the technology
to do uh gps in our phone to locate us
i'm sure everybody here on the planet is
thrilled that we have it but you know
when we we fund basic research
curiosity-driven research and when we
pursue
uh trying to understand the universe we
learn
things that uh eventually they show up
in our technology eventually they better
our lives but you know like any sort of
investment you make some you make in the
sort of high risk high reward category
and i think you know uh these telescopes
sit squarely in that sort of category
and i think a healthy society will
always make those investments because
they want to continue to grow
john any any thoughts on the argument
for spending the sums that we do on
these kinds of seemingly esoteric
sounding scientific explorations yeah
sure well um i draw my inspiration from
the idea that among other things we are
proving that we can do amazing things
so when we say
that telescope looks impossible to build
well we say well we did build it it
probably will work well because we did
what we're supposed to do so it will
survive launch
so
it's a demonstration that humanity can
pull together to do
complex things if it really wants to
so
i'm very appreciative that we were able
to do that and i say also you know we're
now
as i say we're reading the book of
nature and putting it into the books of
man so we're putting our information
into the library that will last forever
and uh that's information that cannot be
lost
so i'm so proud that we're able to do
that as a species
fantastic vienna any any thoughts or do
you have an argument that you give in
response to that query that you must get
yes so i mean certainly whenever you
talk to the general public from very
young the children to to old they are
hugely interested in these big questions
of are we alone um what is the nature of
the universe
um and it drives that curiosity i mean
you see it it also attracts sort of
children to the natural sciences not
necessarily to astronomy but it gets
them into sciences and that's also what
our society needs it needs sort of these
bright minds that are curious
because that actually is a driver for
for innovation
but also more generally i think it's
it's part of our human nature indeed to
ask the biggest questions to be curious
that's that's what makes us human you
know what if as a society we wouldn't be
asking these biggest questions anymore
what does that tell us about our society
we would be very inward looking by by
looking at astronomy by looking at at
the universe by you looking at you know
planets where there may be life
um it makes us very humble also um
provides some humility
some modesty i would say
we are only living on the tiny little
planets there out out in the the big
universe
we live on a beautiful planet we need to
take good care of it that's also one of
the messages that that we can give
um but but in the end it gives us
perspective really of where we are in
this this universe that makes you know a
lot of the conflicts and and other
issues that we're having in society it
puts them in perspective and and maybe
they're not as important to to argue
about as as we think they are so i
always like to say that you know we are
we are all world citizens under the same
beautiful sky and uh that is a message
that we definitely want to give to the
to the public yeah beautiful and vital
perspective natalie want to take us out
with final words
on why it is that we do what we do
i would argue i i live my life as a
scientist with this idea that
all the mysteries of the universe are
knowable
and that motivates me you know what what
is the limit of our knowledge and i
would say maybe there is no limit so
what else is there yet to learn that
will fundamentally change my
understanding of my place in the
universe and why i exist
the this this exploration gives meaning
to my life and gives me comfort that
everything is exactly as it should be
and i'm a vital part of that and
everything is connected and you can't
put a price tag on that
i agree and this conversation i hope
will make everyone who's watching also
feel a vital part of this new era of
exploration discovery which is
who we are as a species so december
2021 is the launch we will be
waiting anxiously to hear how that goes
and we'll also be waiting with baited
breath for the results that will start
pouring in from
all the research that you will be
spearheading as well as our other
scientific colleagues around the world
so it's an exciting time and thank you
so much for taking the time out to
discuss the james webb space telescope
with us here today thank you
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you